bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
auditions publiques sur LCP et Public
Sénat invité une heure pour passer au
crible l'actualité le prix de l'essence
les défaites de Poutine en Ukraine la
crise avec l'Italie sur les migrants
plus largement d'ailleurs la politique
migratoire de la France les crispations
au sein du RN le spectre de la
dissolution et même la coupe du monde de
foot oui toutes les questions vous
seront posées bonjour Jean-Philippe
Tanguy merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce soir sur la chaîne parlementaire
député de la Somme depuis juin dernier
vous avez les 36 ans plus jeune sauf
erreur vous avez été élèves à Saint-Cyr
avant de faire vos classes politiques
celle là auprès de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan
dont vous avez été un proche
collaborateur pendant presque 8 ans je
crois je crois avant de rejoindre le RN
et d'y faire quand même ce qu'on peut
appeler une ascension assez éclaire vous
êtes président délégué du groupe RN à
l'Assemblée voilà pour la présentation
première question elle va porter sur la
de la polémique que vous avez beaucoup
peut animer au RN sur le chêne Viking
sur les 234 personnes qui ont été
accueillies à Toulon à bord de ce navire
seul un tiers des personnes éligibles
aux droits d'asile resteront en France
est-ce qu'on peut sérieusement comme
vous faites au rassemblement national
évoquer une pompe aspirante au sujet de
ce bateau mais en fait ce n'est pas les
200 34 personnes en elle-même qui posent
problème c'est le fait comme la
d'ailleurs monsieur Collomb c'est un
ministre de l'intérieur c'est le
principe c'est-à-dire on a établi un
nouveau principe à savoir que les
bateaux qui seraient refusés par
l'Italie ou par d'autres pays européens
iront donc ou pourront en tout cas aller
en France un principe je rappelle avait
été refusé il y a trois ans puisque le
caste est déjà produit à l'époque
Monsieur Salvini était ministre de
l'Intérieur il avait refusé l'Aquarius
la question s'était posée de savoir si
Marseille d'abord la Corse d'ailleurs
encore puis Marseille elle accueillir et
finalement il est allé à Barcelone la
question c'est ce précédent pourquoi
parce que nous pensons aura son
circonstances de Monsieur Darmanin de la
macronie sur ce sujet mais j'en viens
parce que il faut toujours des
propositions alternatives voilà nous
nous disons juste encore une question
sur d'autres pays de demander l'asile
depuis on va venir mais plus que parler
du principe vous avez rappelé à juste
titre qu'on avait la France avait refusé
à l'époque l'Aquarius est-ce que ça a
fait baisser le nom d'un migrants non
parce que donc vous dites voilà le
principe effectivement il donne le
signal à ceux qui veulent venir chez
nous pour des raisons plus ou moins
légitimes que c'est possible mais le
refus de l'aquarium ça peut fait baisser
le nombre de candidats à la migration en
France vous avez raison parce que nous
l'aurons vu qu'on veut ce sont tout port
européen c'est un refus de tout port
européen et que le les bateaux une fois
qu'ils sont évidemment sauvés ça je fais
le précise parce que il est évident
qu'il faut toujours sauver les personnes
qui sont sur des embarcations précaires
ou dangereuses mais une fois qu'elles
sont sauvées qu'éventuellement elles
sont soignées d'ailleurs en mer par des
bateaux médicalisés militaires qui
existent on les renvoie vers les ports
africains musk effectivement le port est
arrivé à Barcelone et après comme il y a
la libre circulation aussi de l'Union
européenne d'une part et l'accord de
Dublin d'autre part vous avez les
migrants qui ont la capacité de
s'installer dans les pays qui le
souhaitent alors qu'est-ce que vous
faites notre solution vous êtes au
pouvoir d'abord ce bateau vous le
rejetez vous le repoussez le bateau
voilà le bateau le bateau
viking oui effectivement lui dit vous
repartez et vous débarquez vers les
ports africains soit la Tunisie ce qu'on
appelle les portures vous savez les
portes Tunisiens sont des ports sur les
ports algériens sont des portures Y a
l'exception de la Libye on est d'accord
ou là il ne s'agit pas de portion donc
il faut les ramener vers les ports en
fait des pays émetteurs d'ailleurs ils
le savent très bien et pas les ramener
vers vers les pays européens parce
qu’est-ce qu’il faut savoir quand on
voit la carte où ces personnes sont
récupérées sur les embarcations
dangereuses en mer c'est souvent
extrêmement proche pour de des côtes en
fait africaines et après c'est qu'une
fois que l'océan Lucian Viking ou
d'autres bateaux sont revenus vers les
côtes européennes qui se maintenant
n'est plus proches des côtes européennes
mais c'est pas vrai qui les ont pas avec
si vous voulez dans certaines
couvertures médiatiques pas forcément
ici on a l'impression que les migrants
sont arrivés proches des côtes
siciliennes maltaises ou sarde non en
fait ces personnes ont été récupérées
bien bien plus tôt et donc l'autre
solution ensuite c'est que nous on veut
que les demandeurs d'asile fasse leur
demande depuis les consulats français ou
d'autres pays à l'étranger ce qui
permettra de les maintenir sur place
d'avoir la disposition et de suivre cela
vous savez par exemple on n'est pas pour
mais il y a des certains pays européens
qui ont fait des prix des mesures encore
plus radicales par exemple le Danemark
qui est dérivé par des
sociaux-démocrates ont même délégué la
gestion de leur demande d'asile à un
pays d'Afrique centrale le Rwanda pardon
alors sur les solutions il reviendra
dans ces quelques instants avec Brigitte
Boucher est un train oui mais quand même
sur le principe combien d'ukrainien
ont-ils été accueilli en Europe et par
la France par exemple depuis le début de
la guerre je n'ai pas de vous mentir
j'ai pas le nombre en tête mais c'est un
nombre conséquent enfin d'ailleurs
beaucoup moins que nos amis polonais ou
d'autres pays d'Europe centrale 97000 en
France
116000 en Italie
c'est quoi le problème de ce bateau
c'est l'Origin ethnique des livres pour
l'Ukraine d'une part l'Ukraine est un
pays envahi c'est un pays en guerre au
sens du droit international c'est non
contestable ensuite les réfugiés sont
des personnes qui ne peuvent pas se
défendre puisque ce sont des maires de
famille des personnes âgées des enfants
en très grande majorité les hommes en
âge de se battent ou en âge de avec les
migrants
n'étaient pas ni des anglais ni des
Espagnols ni de non mais c'était des
pays mais l'autre un autre principe
parce que un peu oublié vous savez un
des grands principes du droit des
réfugiés c'est aussi la proximité
géographique c'est affirmé dans la
charte de Genève du hacer du
Haut-Commissariat pour les réfugiés il
va y avoir une on vient de loin moi on a
le droit à la ville en France oui enfin
c'est de l'inverse c'est qu'en fait vous
devez les les réfugiés devaient
accueilli le plus proche possible du
pays ou de la zone de guerre c'est un
principe qui a été oublié madame
martichou qui est important du Haut
Commissariat réfugié parce qu'en fait le
la position de base des réfugiés c'est
pas que il s'installe de manière pérenne
dans les pays d'accueil c'est qu'ils
puissent retourner dans le leur pays
une fois qu'elle a crise est passée par
exemple vous prenez la crise israélienne
la crise en Palestine c'est pour ça que
les beaucoup de
mélanger mais en tout cas ce qui nous
intéresse c'est l'efficacité ils ont été
mis en les réfugiés palestiniens ont été
mis au Liban en Jordanie parce que il y
avait le principe de la proximité
géographique Brigitte boucher pour elle
CP est un train de vous et vont
poursuivre encore quelques instants
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet Tom oui votre
réaction à ce déclarations de Gérard
Collomb lex ministre de l'Intérieur qui
dénonce une brèche créant un précédent
avec lacostage de lotion Viking à Toulon
c'est un allié inattendu pour vous un
allié non parce que moi je ne veux pas
manipuler ou être de mauvaise foi par
rapport aux déclarations de ce que l'on
il reste dans sa famille politique mais
il dit quelque chose d'important c'est
déjà y rejoint notre analyse sur le fait
effectivement que ça crée un précédent
grave qui peut malheureusement nourrir
notamment les passeurs et les la
philosophie les promesses que ces
trafiquants d'êtres humains font au
pauvres personnes qui leur font
confiance d'une part et d'autre part par
vous applaudissez non mais applaudir non
parce que par contre moi je ne comprends
pas que Monsieur Collomb dans une
démocratie dans une république les
responsables politiques n'ont pas à
dissimuler des choses aux Français ils
n'ont pas à mentir par omission français
moi ce qui m'a choqué dans Monsieur dans
les dégâts sont monsieur colon c'est
qu'en tant que responsable politique de
première ordre il si vraiment la
motivation de sa démission était
justifiée par ce choix-là il aurait dû
en avertir les Français et dire je ne
l'ai pas fait parce que j'avais pas de
Marine Le Pen ça ne me semble pas du
tout républicain une fois effectivement
il a dit qu'il n'a pas voulu en parler
avec l'élection présidentielle pour que
cela n'influence pas le vote en faveur
de Marine Le Pen c'était beaucoup plus
tôt il a pas démissionné à la veille de
la présidentielle sinon je ne sais pas
moi je refais pas les élections je pense
pas non plus que la vie de Monsieur
colon aurait bouleversé les Français
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que vous
savez il y a quand même des principes
j'ai l'impression qu'on les oublie un
peu dans notre pays nous sommes une
démocratie on n'est pas un régime
autoritaire on n'est pas un régime où
les gens peuvent pas s'exprimer et les
responsables politiques ont un devoir de
transparence et de vérité envers les
citoyens français qui doit faire leur
choix et leur vote de manière
parfaitement éclairée donc le fait
d'avoir de bonnes foi de mauvaise
vérité ou une information importante aux
Français et je trouve que pour un
responsable politique et en plus le
ministre de l'Intérieur et le gardien
des élections est particulièrement grave
Marine Le Pen dit que l'Italie doit
respecter le droit international et en
même temps quel soutient Georgia Meloni
est-ce que c'est pas un peu
contradictoire vous savez il y a avant
il y a quand même le sort des urnes
voilà les urnes n'ont parlé madame
Meloni au moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'elle a annoncé avec ses alliés en
particulier Matéo Salvini qu'il avait
déjà fait on a parlé quand il était
ministre de l'intérieur elle a dit
qu'elle ne l'accepterait plus ça après
il faut aussi sauf que c'est le droit
international mais il faut dire aussi la
vérité le droit international il doit
s'appliquer tout le temps est-ce que les
partenaires européens l'Italie ont
appliqué leurs engagements non j'étais
sur l'autre soir avec votre collègue
plus rien oui madame Ferrari a révélé je
ne savais pas que la France n'avait pas
respecté de son engagement et que sur
plusieurs milliers de migrants que qui
devaient venir qu'on devait récupérer
pour aider être solidaire de l'Italie on
avait pris 38 voilà donc visible les
engagements internationaux c'est pas
tout le monde doit les respecter la
France dit il y aura des représailles
puisque vous n'avez pas accueilli alors
déjà moi par contre dire un allié comme
l'Italie qui est quand même presque un
pays frères pour pas dire que c'est un
pays frère parler de représailles parce
qu'on a un désaccord sur la gestion d'un
navire ce qu'on adresse
quand on est en Europe on est en Europe
reste de la mer c'est que le bateau doit
repartir de là où il est plus proche il
a été lotion de Viking intervient à
quelques dizaines de de kilomètres des
côtes africaines en l'occurrence
tunisienne pour ce navire là donc le si
on avait appliqué le droit international
on aurait pas ramené le bateau vers les
côtes européennes mais vers le côte
africaine donc déjà le droit
international c'est pas géométrie
variable mais après là où même si je
suis évidemment patriote et je les fera
toujours la France avant je dois
reconnaître que la France n'a pas
respecté ses engagements envers l'Italie
donc on peut pas on ne peut pas
reprocher aussi à l'Italie de lancer un
cri d'alarme en disant ça suffit parce
que défendez pas la France là dans ce
cas précis là mais défendre la France
c'est pas être aveugle aussi sur les
mauvais engagements ou les promesses non
tenues des gouvernements qui nous
représentent une fois plus l'Italie
avait lancé un premier cri d'alarme il y
a 3 ans avec Monsieur Salvini avec
l'Aquarius bon soi-disant d'éclairer la
situation est-ce que ça a été géré
depuis non les accords ne sont pas rosés
sur la France on aurait très bien pu
renvoyer le bateau vers les côtés
et vous pouvez faire intervenir un
bateau médicalisé militaire c'est des
bateaux qui soignent nos troupes en
quatre personnes évacuées une personne
qui est des bateaux à l'hôpital bien sûr
mais il y a des bateaux qui sont équipés
il faut revenir aussi ça fait quand même
des plusieurs semaines qu'on traîne
laisse aussi traîner ce bateau donc
maintenant tout le monde veut intervenir
en urgence on aurait très bien plus il y
a beaucoup de choses encore oui
immigration qui va arriver au Parlement
au début de l'année prochaine est-ce que
vous êtes favorable au fait d'inscrire
les personnes sous octf au fichier des
personnes recherchées au QF obligation
de quitter le territoire français oui
bah de toute façon nous voyait plus loin
puisqu'on veut rétablir ce que Monsieur
Hollande avait supprimé à savoir la
criminalisation de la clandestinité ça a
été supprimé récemment quand vous étiez
clandestin en France c'était un délit
voilà donc de toute façon il y avait des
procédures judiciaires qui allaient avec
comme celle-ci voilà donc ça on est pas
vraiment à cette mesure
un délice le nombre de qtf exerce enfin
appliqué pardon ne cesse de se dégrader
jusqu'à des chiffres extrêmement
inquiétants voilà bon donc il y a eu des
augmentations après il y a pas une
dégradation continue du nombre des
occupants
mais si vous prenez tous les chiffres
cumulés c'est une dégradation constante
d'ailleurs même le reconnaissent puisque
monsieur Macron a plusieurs reprises
monsieur Darmanin dans sa suite c'était
engagé je crois dans valeur à exécuter
100% actuelle c'est une partie du parc
du projet
son nouveau titre ces valeurs c'est une
partie du projet de loi que vous
pourriez voter ah oui mais nous on n'est
jamais pour la politique du pire donc
même s'il y a une petite mesure qui va
dans le bon sens même si on n'est pas
d'accord avec la philosophie generale du
texte qui reste de l'égaliser des
nouvelles filières de de d'immigration
on pourrait voter des mesures
ponctuelles par exemple il paraît qu'ils
veulent aussi diminuer le nombre de
recours exactement bon bah simplifier
c'est très bien donc les procédures
contre les moins de catégories de
recours ça si vous le votez oui nous ne
sommes jamais dans la politique du pire
donc on prend ce qui est à prendre pour
que la situation non pas s'améliore mais
soit moins dramatique sur le reste par
exemple la régularisation alors
justement
des étrangers qui occupent des métiers
en tension hier Marine Le Pen a dit dans
le Journal du Dimanche les étrangers au
chômage doivent rentrer chez eux donc là
ça veut dire quoi un immigré qui
travaille qui paye des impôts il peut
rester sur le sol français donc vous
êtes finalement d'accord avec cette loi
un immigré en situation légale peut
rester en France évidemment et nous le
remercions d'ailleurs pour son travail
pour notre pays un immigré clandestin
doit rentrer chez lui
même
dans la société même si il parle le
français et ce n'est pas une fois plus
contre les personnes parce que à titre
individuel vous allez trouver des gens
très courageux qui travaillent très bien
évidemment la situation est que ces
personnes sont rentrées sur le
territoire ou sont demeuré sur le
territoire de manière clandestine de
manière illégale même si ce sont des
front qui les emploie de manière
clandestine donc en fait c'est oui mais
moi une forme de complicité
les patrons tout ne revient pas alors
vous devrez pénaliser tous les
restaurateurs de France à peu près vous
y allez dans les références comment ça
se passe oui bien sûr
pendant 5 ans effectivement il y avait
une partie qui pouvait
non c'est pas démagogie mais il faut
rétablir des principes à la martichou le
problème aussi de l'image qu'à la France
dans les pays émetteur d'immigration
c'est qu'on sait que de toute façon les
principes ne sont pas appliqués donc il
faut appliquer des principes simples
quand vous êtes rentrés de manière
illégale ou demeurer de manière illégale
sur le territoire même si vous êtes
quelqu'un de bien parce que moi j'étais
choqué par exemple monsieur darmanie il
y a des immigrés méchants dans des pays
qui sont méchants il y a des migrés qui
respectent la loi les immigrés qui ne
respectent pas la loi même s'ils ont
d'autres qualités ces personnes doivent
être ramener chez elle ce qui n'empêche
pas s'ils ont des qualifications après
de redemander de redemander un titre de
séjour valable si évidemment la France a
besoin d'eux un débat sur l'immigration
il faut rester quelque chose vous savez
ça fait aussi moi depuis que je suis né
excusez-moi on parle de la crise
immigrate migratoire on les lois
s'accumulent s'accumule s'accumule à la
situation et toujours pire donc il faut
rétablir des principes simples quelqu'un
qui est rentré Mania illégale sur le
territoire quel que soit ses qualités
doivent partir un débat sur
l'immigration doit avoir lieu à
l'Assemblée au de décembre qu'est-ce que
vous en attendez est-ce que ce serait
bien qu'il y ait des quotas qui soit
votés par les députés pour faire venir
un certain nombre d'immigrés dans ces
métiers les quotas c'est l'art les Ian
faire venir des gens pour travailler
vous savez il y a pas besoin de main
d'oeuvre aujourd'hui d'ailleurs c'est
Monsieur Sarkozy à l'époque qui avait
lancé le sujet vous avez 30 milliards
d'euros à peu près par an qui sont
consacrés à la formation vous avez
grosso modo 10% de chômeurs bon si la
France n'est pas capable de mettre en
adéquation 30 milliards d'euros de
formation et 10% de chômeurs c'est que
c'est le système de formation qui
déconne c'est pas la question de
l'immigration deuxième sujet la question
des salaires mais aussi des conditions
de travail parce qu'on parle toujours
des salaires mais moi une fois plus
j'étais serveur quand vous arrivez vous
faites le service du midi que j'étais en
Île-de-France vous n'avez pas le temps
de rentrer chez vous donc en fait vous
restez 4 5 6 heures
de manière stérile sans être payé et
sans pouvoir faire autre chose c'est un
problème de conditions de travail qui
peut mettre sur la table donc il faut
régler ses problèmes là parce que c'est
dans les migration dans les Français qui
quittent la France pour aller travailler
ailleurs vous avez beaucoup de personnes
de la restauration qui en fait aime bien
leur métier savent sont des sons des
professionnels mais je choisis d'aller
travailler en dehors de la France donc
il faut poser ces questions là et vous
avez après une petite part de métier par
vous avez des médecins vous avez
certaines professions médicales mais
c'est ce sont des tout petits secteurs
vous avez des scientifiques évidemment
mais il y a pas besoin
de lui ce titre d'ailleurs les médecins
étrangers vont par ailleurs on aurait
pas besoin de mettre ça à l'étranger si
ceux qui parlent aujourd'hui des
médecins étrangers avaient pas fait
numéro de clausus mais c'est un ou deux
catégories donc aujourd'hui bien sûr on
n'a jamais été pour envoyer les médecins
ou les soignants ou des gens qui
travaillent de manière légale parce que
ça c'est pas des clandestins mais ce que
je vais vous dire c'est que ce sont une
toute petite catégorie et ce n'est pas
les 500 000 les 500 000 personnes dont
on parle il y a la loi de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur qui est
débattu en ce moment à l'Assemblée
nationale elle prévoit plus d'effectif
d'un police dans la gendarmerie pour la
cybersécurité au total c'est 15
milliards d'euros en plus pour pour la
sécurité ce que vous allez la voter mais
écoutez c'est pas impossible qu'on la
vote d'une part déjà le fait qu'une loi
de programmation sur les moyens c'était
une proposition ancienne du programme de
Marine Le Pen donc déjà on a obtenu le
fait que ce soit programmé qui doit
programmation donc on s'en félicite même
si on aurait préféré et je crois que
Monsieur Darmanin le penser aussi que ce
soit aussi une programmation de la
justice puisqu'il évidemment les deux
doivent fonctionner main dans la main
nous avons fait plusieurs amendements et
si ces amendements pas tous on n'est pas
royaliste que le roi mais si certains
amendements importants sont repris les
possibles qu'on vote cette loi avec vos
amendements
a l'air de nous reconnaître beaucoup de
qualité dans le domaine de la sécurité
mais ça c'est une des conditions au vote
de la loi bah oui c'est vrai que la loi
est imparfaite donc on espère
l'améliorer après ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on ne votera pas contre puisque il y
a des moyens pour la police et voilà
voilà on ne sera pas une fois plus la
politique du pire
il propose vous pouvez faire des choses
bien sans être un bon ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin c'est
quand même le commentateur de
l'Intérieur surtout il passe sa vie à
commenter bon je vais pas reparler de
l'imami cousine ou des stades de France
mais je suis pas sûr qu'il soit si bon
que ça alors votre partie régulièrement
mise en cause pour ses relations avec la
Russie dans les médias par des hommes
politiques dernier épisode en date
Julien Bayou qui a envoyé la semaine
dernière un signalement au procureur de
la République à propos du financement du
rassemblement national par des sociétés
russes votre réaction bah écoutez il a
fait une revue de presse puisque moi je
l'ai vu ça l'être c'est les articles qui
sont déjà connus donc il y a pas en quoi
il apporte quelque chose il veut sans
doute faire oublier des choses moins
glorieuses de son côté nous vous savez
on a fait une demande sa situation
personnelle oui parce qu'en fait c'est
vraiment envie de se sais pas si vous
avez lu l'entièreté
en commission toutes plus ordurières
possibles contre le rassemble national
mais c'est une vie technique de la Gaule
c'est quand ils sont chopés dans des
situations un peu fâcheuses ils font de
la ils font le sexe c'est ce que je me
suis Pasqua quand vous avez une affaire
faut créer une autre affaire voilà donc
monsieur Bayou a l'air de bien connaître
le son pour lui c'est la première
constitue un financement illégal et
déjà on a regardé le contenu pour voir
si on pouvait pas avoir une réaction
comportement monsieur Bayou mais sur le
fond vous savez puisque c'est moi qui
est l'honneur de de la présider si nos
adversaires acceptent nous avons demandé
une commission d'enquête parlementaire
sur les ingérences étrangères y compris
les ingérences russes il n'y a aucun
problème pour mettre ça sur la table
pourquoi je veux que on se débarrasse de
ce que je croisais est un poison pour le
débat démocratique français ça fait des
années maintenant qu'on a mais pas
seulement le RN parce que quand Monsieur
Mélenchon menaçait un peu le système
aussi il avait été accusé de Jésus quel
lien que le Venezuela bon il fait quand
même pas une commission juste pour
prouver que vous n'avez pas de lien avec
la rue sinon c'est pour mettre moins un
terme à ces accusations parce que vous
savez dans les démocraties et d'ailleurs
c'est une journaliste j'avais un
entretien très intéressant avec elle qui
me parlait de la situation pour
l'Algérie le fait d'accuser l'opposition
d'être le parti de l'étranger ou d'être
le parti 2 plusieurs puissances
étrangères c'est vraiment un poison pour
la démocratie parce qu'on a l'impression
que des gens quel que soit leur partie
d'ailleurs de défendre plus la France
donc il faut payer une clarté je
rappelle dans cette commission c'est pas
la Commission à l'égard de pendant des
années à propos de clarté c'est-à-dire
parce qu'elle est allée lui rendre
visite il y aura à quel point il était
un bon Président vous avez obtenu un
prêt auprès d'une banque russe donc
polien avec la Russie au Front national
puis au RN sont avérés elle a rencontré
Monsieur Poutine il doit être une
demi-heure en 20 ans donc moi je veux
bien que ce soit très important mais
beaucoup de responsables politiques
français rencontré Monsieur Poutine je
rappelle que depuis Jacques Chirac
l'amitié avec la Russie n'était pas une
toute tabou voilà donc on ne peut pas
juger si vous voulez une relation passée
par le fait que Monsieur Poutine et
envahit de manière illégale et
criminelle l'Ukraine parce que dans ce
cas là il y a beaucoup de notamment chez
l'air beaucoup de responsables français
qui auraient un problème et le lien avec
le prêt n'a pas de lien en tout cas à
faire
vous dites que vous allez quand même
présider la commission d'enquête est-ce
que vous savez déjà qui sera le
rapporteur de travail
moi je l'aurais on aura des voix mais
nous serons minoritaires dans la
commission donc c'est pas nous qui
allons tout diriger je rassure tout de
suite ceux qui nous écoutent il y a une
ristourne à la pompe qui va s'arrêter
demain le litre d'essence va donc
repartir à la hausse est-ce que vous
craignez une colère sociale dans le pays
ah bah je oui je la crainte je l'annoncé
vous savez la semaine dernière mardi
dernier on avait le vote du projet de
loi de finance rectif pour la fin de
l'année j'ai dit à Monsieur Attal à la
fin nous ne votons contre votre budget
parce que vous ne poursuivez pas la
ristourne ça va créer des problèmes
sociales ça va créer des opportunités
c'est à dire qu'il y a des gens donc
justement il y avait une prolongation
d'Aristote jusqu'au 15 novembre donc
c'est déjà une prolongation mais il
s'avère que l'exercice budgétaire là
comme vous avez justement dit à
quelqu'un qui était déjà fait puisqu'on
a voté la loi il y avait déjà la moitié
du prolongement qui était passé mais je
l'ai dit à Monsieur Attal
pas forcément contesté qu'en fait il
n'arriverait pas à sortir de ce
processus de l'aristobe donc il faut
prolonger l'Aristote jusqu'à la fin de
l'année et parallèlement vous savez que
j'ai aussi fait une demande dans le
projet de loi de finance de 2023 il y a
j'ai découvert en fait que selon les
cris du ministère même la ristourne de
30 centimes n'avait été appliqué
répercuté sur les prix qu'à moitié
environ entre 14 et 16 centimes donc les
demander à la président de la commission
des finances une mission flash pour
qu'on comprenne où était passé l'argent
donc vous allez l'amener cette c'est
vous
c'est pas là pour mener en tout cas non
mais le président m'a dit que c'était
intéressant j'ai fait une erreur télé
transparente j'ai fait une erreur
technique dans le but de la saisine mais
je pense que ça va se faire tremper
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
il y a Olivier Véran qui a dit quand
même que ça allait se poursuivre qu'il y
aurait quand même des aides pour près de
12 millions de Français on ne connaît
pas encore le dispositif mais des aides
plus ciblées ça va quand même dans le
bon sens non parce que si vous voulez
faut pas cibler vous avez les
travailleurs vous avez les retraités
vous avez les maires les les pères de
famille tout le monde a besoin de sa
voiture en réalité je vais vous donner
un exemple il y a des gens qui peuvent
payer et d'autres
c'est ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui
travaillent pas donc pareil je vous
donne un exemple je recevais en
permanence dans la Somme avoir la ballon
et à béancourt ce weekend un père de
famille son fils a été pris dans une
formation d'excellence à Airbus la seule
façon il y a pas de bus il y a pas de
train les routes sont dangereuses il va
pas prendre le vélo la seule raison
qu'il a c'est d'amener son fils en
voiture d'accord la seule façon qu'il a
et ce monsieur n'est pas beaucoup
d'argent mais son fils au travail qu'il
soit éligible dernière question Tom oui
lou Boyard annonce qui va porter plainte
contre Cyril Hanouna après ses propos
insultants dans son émission est-ce que
vous le soutenez le Boyard vous en tant
que parlementaire
non mais je me soutiens pas dans le sens
où si vous voulez il nourrit
malheureusement ce qui s'est passé
c'était tout est déplorable dans cette
histoire et Monsieur Boyard a fait sa
carrière là-dessus voilà il a accès
Hanouna et quelques années donc vous
serez Cyril quand vous réclame quand
vous vous intervenez dans Touche pas
mais enfin dans cette émission pour de
dire avec fierté que vous avez été un
dealer et après vous étonn que moi après
que la personne qui vous reçoivent ne
vous considère pas que vous soyez un
député exemplaire voilà il a nourri le
système dans lequel il s'est lui-même
fait de retrouver beaucoup d'hommes
politiques sont aussi rentrés dans cette
couche
qui ont gagné si vous vouliez comme pas
beaucoup d'hommes politiques étaient
payés par Monsieur Hanouna ou par le
groupe Bolloré voilà donc si vous voulez
foirer cette hypocrisie moi je trouve ça
me suivez ce que dit Cyril Hanouna oui
pour qu'on insulte
tout ça c'est de l'hypocrisie il y a une
scène qui a déplorable mais monsieur
Boyard a nourri
pour finir normal que l'arcome qui a été
saisi par exemple sanctionne au titre du
respect des personnes dans le cas dans
l'audiovisuel sanctionne Hanouna le fait
qu'on est pas loin d'insulter quelqu'un
à la télé je suis d'accord mais je veux
pas que Monsieur Boyard passe pour une
victime c'est lui qui avait refusé de
vous hein
le lendemain il avait quand même traité
les députés reine de maladies d'une
épidémie donc faut quand même voir
l'individu merci beaucoup brigitte est
un Vincent ou tout de suite en direct du
figarolive bonjour Vincent vous avez une
question justement sur un parlementaire
pour Louis Boyard pour pour
Jean-Philippe
Tanguy bonsoir cher Isabelle alors on va
rester justement avec la France
insoumise
estimez-vous comme Sandrine Rousseau
Jean-Philippe Tanguy que le retour
d'Adrien catenas et pour l'instant
impossible à l'Assemblée nationale oui
moi titre personnel je pense que que
c'est impossible après le principe
général du groupe c'est que c'est aux
électeurs seuls de choisir c'est vrai
que ce seul un député peut être envoyé
seulement par ses électeurs après je le
trouve ce qui complètement
incompréhensible d'ailleurs j'entendais
monsieur Roussel aussi ce matin qui
avait la même position que que Madame
Rousseau c'est que compte tenu des
positions des insoumis pour le coup
ajuste titre contre les violences
conjugales ils sont pris un total
incohérence voilà donc moi je lui à
titre personnel je pense que Monsieur
catenens devrait appliquer en fait les
principes qu'il a voulu appliquer à la
société française et démissionner ces
principes sont pas des principes
réglementaires notamment de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a la bonne privée qui est
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
disait aujourd'hui rien n'empêche
Adrien catenas de siéger sur les bancs
de l'Assemblée nationale vous voudriez
par exemple qui est une réunion du
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale c'est un
cas de conscience c'est un cas de
conscience de Monsieur catenas qu'ici
les cohérent avec ce qu'il a toujours
dit devrait démissionner voilà moi c'est
mon avis après politiquement un député
est élu par les Français il y a que les
Français qui ont le droit de le juger
voilà mais s'ils sont cohérents comment
même sur la base d'affaires privées ah
bah de toute façon les Français c'est
plus privé maintenant c'est public donc
le moi mais moi je vous dis s'il était
cohérent il devrait démissionner et en
plus je trouve que ça envoie un signal
extrêmement dangereux et je pèse mes
mots à la société française si la
société française qui s'était Camille
beaucoup de temps qui a eu beaucoup de
temps quel que soit les parties
d'ailleurs à se mobiliser contre les
violences faites aux femmes on envoie le
signal que quand vous êtes députés si
vous passez à la télé et que vous dites
vous êtes désolé c'est pas si grave je
trouve que c'est un signal extrêmement
dangereux et moi ça me je suis assez
inquiet sur les conséquences que ça va
avoir sur la société une partie
évidemment de la société en française
parce que ce problème des femmes très
courageuses et des hommes d'ailleurs ont
mis très longtemps à le mettre sur sur
le devant de la scène politique et les
résultats même si pour le coup le
gouvernement on fait quelque chose sont
lents parce que c'était pas représenter
les français si on a avoué avoir giflé
sa femme moi je pense que non mais c'est
ma position
merci beaucoup Vincent roux à tout à
l'heure bien sûr pour une autre question
à Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonjour ou plutôt
bonsoir Sophie dravidal merci d'être
avec nous
journaliste bien sûr politique au Figaro
c'est à vous merci on va faire un petit
peu de politique intérieure
rassemblement national vous avez eu un
congrès du renouveau un nouveau patron à
la tête du parti Jordan Bardell trois
jeunes donc ce renouveau en même temps
et il y a eu dans les jours qui
précédaient dans les heures qui
précédaient des tensions assez fortes
avec des figures anciennes du parti je
pense assez Briois Bruno Bilde etc qui
ont dénoncé ensuite pendant ce même
congrès à bougrissement de la ligne une
ligne jugée dure qui est celle sur
laquelle si je ne me trompe vous êtes
inscrit et ils ont dénoncé des purges
est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez et qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à tous ces électeurs et reine du Nord
qu'ils ont parfois peut-être inquiets de
voir leurs élus comme ça déstabilisés
qu'est-ce qui se passe en interne je
pense pas que nos électeurs soient
déstabilisés qui tordent la somme tout
ce week-end je crois que ça intéresse
peu de voilà les sociétés de façon les
histoires partisanes n'intéresse pas je
pense pas beaucoup mais voilà Steve Rewa
et Bruno Bill sont mes amis donc moi je
vous dis ce que je leur ai dit je pense
qu'ils sont déçus je comprends qu'ils
soient déçu par le résultat puisqu'il
soutenaient Louis Aliot Louis Aliou a
fait un très beau discours où il a
reconnu là évidemment la victoire de
Jordan il a expliqué qu'il y avait pas
de problème de ligne la ligne sociale
c'est Marine Le Pen Jordan mardella
Marine Le Pen lui avait confié la
présence par intérim donc il y avait
aucun problème de ligne d'ailleurs
Marine Le Pen a dit à plusieurs reprises
que si un des candidats avec quitté sa
ligne historique elle serait intervenue
sur une remise en cause de la ligne
sociale mais pas du tout vous savez
Jordan quand il a été par des lapin
quand il a été promu aux européennes il
était au contraire présenté comme une
personnalité moderne pardon c'était le
premier qui avait reconnu que évidemment
on en reviendrait jamais sur le sur le
mariage pour tous voilà moi je me suis
soutenu Jordan Bardella mais je pense
pas être la ligne dure puisque sur les
questions sociétales je suis plutôt même
très progressiste et sur la ligne
sociale je l'ai soutenu à 200%
c'est-à-dire que sur tous les grandes
questions qui ont été arbitrées ces
dernières années sur le match pour tous
sur l'adoption j'ai toujours été en
faveur de ces combats bien avant même de
faire de la politique voilà donc ce que
je veux dire et ensuite sur la ligne
sociale j'étais un ardent défenseur des
fois de Marine Le Pen sur le pouvoir
d'achat encore en séance je suis le
référent sur les questions sur les lois
de finances je défends sur les sur
profits par exemple c'est moi désolé de
me tirer la couverture à moi mais c'est
factuel suite à l'audition à la mission
flash sur les profits pétroliers c'est
moi qui ont commission et dit à mes
collègues il faut faire une taxe sur les
sur achats d'action et sur les sorcières
dividendes donc je pense pas qu'on
puisse imaginer plus mesures sociales
que ces deux taxes à propos de vous ou
de Jordan Bardella Marine Le Pen a
déclaré qu'elle ne souhaitait pas être
Premier ministre que s'il y avait une
dissolution dont on va parler ensuite il
n'y aurait pas de campagne à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avec une annonce voilà
là-dessus
imaginez-vous majoritaire vous auriez
quelle place vous dans un gouvernement
est-ce que vous vous imaginez vous-même
vous savez déjà via des trélus mais
essayez d'imaginer c'est déjà de
l'imaginer dans les instabilités
financières énergétiques industrielle
moi c'est le combat de ma vie c'est la
réalité
là où je suis franchement moi je pense
que vous savez on est peu de choses et
il faut se concentrer sur ce qu'on a
c'est déjà on a le cas beaucoup de
chance quand je vois la Société
française des difficultés qu'on ne
compatriotes on est des privilégiés donc
déjà ayant conscience de la chance qu'on
a de les servir de servir les enfants
Premier ministre c'est ce qui est
imaginé si jamais ça n'était pas je ne
sais pas sincèrement c'est une question
à partir du moment
Premier ministre on se dit qui peut être
revenir mais c'est Madame artifou j'ai
pas dit que la question de la Ravinel ou
la route était pas sérieuse je n'ai pas
de réponse à votre question non parce
que la question se pose pas de donner
plusieurs noms s'il y avait une campagne
s'il y avait une campagne législative la
question se poser
l'addition et je pense que en fait
me paraît plus un tout petit fantôme
pour faire peur à Weller que voilà vous
savez c'est aussi oui oui c'est vrai
qu'il y ait des chansons à majorité
c'est vrai que moi je puisse préoccupé
par LR parce que c'est je viens de cette
famille politique a très très longtemps
donc les connaît bien et que je sais
comment il raisonne et je sais qu'il
raisonne beaucoup par intérêt personnel
donc je pense qu'ils ont très ils sont
très inquiets de d'une dissolution qui
serait évidemment référendum pour ou
contre la politique Macron donc nous qui
sont entre les deux je pense qu'il
serait écrasé comment vous n'y croyez
pas vous-même ça pose plusieurs
problèmes alors Monsieur Macron à une
personnalité qui fait que ça c'est pas
impossible je pense qu'il aime pas du
tout être contraint je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui n'aime pas les
contre-pouvoirs quelqu'un qui n'aime pas
du tout être limité dans ses aspirations
comment voilà je pense qu'il n'est pas
du tout à l'aise avec la situation mais
au-delà de ça il y a comme des
institutions heureusement en France ça
ne dépend pas de la volonté d'un homme
et le fait quand même de dire aux
électeurs qui ont voté il y a très peu
de temps en fait la façon dont vous avez
voté de me va pas alors qu'il n'y a pas
de blocage du Parlement voilà vous vous
êtes des commentatrices avisés de la
situation les lois passent assez
rapidement les discussions ne sont pas
enlisées et voilà la France a un but en
même temps une dissolution vous seriez
prêt ah oui non on est prêt nous si vous
voulez investiture les comités les
commissions d'investiture ça peut rouler
c'est aucun problème on sort d'une
élection donc déjà la plupart des
candidats je pense seraient justement
est-ce que par exemple monsieur de
Fournas serait réinvesti et bien sûr
qu'il serait réinvestis bien sûr et oui
puisque la machination des insoumis à
abouti à une situation surréaliste ou
l'accusation de base est tombée et il a
été condamné pour le tumulte cacahuète
dans adversaires ça veut dire que
n'importe quel groupe adversaire peut
faire un tumulte contre un député enfin
ça n'a ni que ni tête et donc il n'y a
aucun souci et pas de souci vous vous
voudriez vous imaginer vous êtes 89
aujourd'hui vous imaginez si jamais il y
avait quand même une dissolution parce
qu'il faut quand même accepter de se
projeter vous vous imaginez quoi vous
auriez aucun problème à trouver de quoi
doubler votre corps à l'Assemblée en
termes de candidat si vous respectez les
élections vous regardez ça avec
militaire moi je pense qu'on est prêt je
pense que les électeurs apprécient en
tout cas moi je vois dans ma
circonscription sont contents de la
façon est satisfait de la façon dont on
exerce notre mandat que la ligne qui a
choisi Marine Le Pen d'être à la fois
une opposition constructive mais très
sur l'essentiel de pas être dans la
politique du pire mais d'être toujours
intransigeant sur le programme pour
lequel on a été élu et les valeurs qui
nous ont porté à notre mandat je pense
que les électeurs sont très satisfaits
et qu'autre chose il y a un verrou
psychologique qui a sauté en juin c'est
à dire que le scrutin une nominal à deux
tours majoritaire sur un circonscription
était très dur pour le RN et nos
électeurs parfois pensaient que c'était
impossible je pense que le verrou de la
possibilité d'envoyer 90 donc pourquoi
pas beaucoup plus de députés à sauter et
que c'est un précédent très important de
la politique française dernière question
dernière question sur une niche
parlementaire en janvier on nous dit que
vous n'avez pas encore décidé de se sur
quoi elle allait porter ce sera au
moment des discussions au Sénat au moins
me semble-t-il sur l'immigration donc
évidemment ce sont vos bases est-ce que
vous pourriez nous surprendre avec
qu'est-ce qui pourrait qu'est-ce que
vous pourriez avancer à l'Assemblée
susceptible de surprendre vos électeurs
ou de surprendre les Français non je
pense pas que ça allait surprenne je
pense que ce sera des propositions qui
connaissent qui sont donc absolument et
que ce sera bah ça je peux ça pas été
décidé ni au bureau
c'est les grands thèmes du rassemblement
national c'est la sécurité le pouvoir
d'achat la démocratie
là vous maîtriez quoi en premier je
pense que le pouvoir d'achat est
toujours fondamental et que la situation
en janvier sera terrible parce que là ce
sera plus la disparaison ce sera plus la
diminution de l'artiste tourne ce sera
la suppression totale donc on va voir
l'augmentation
des factures d'électricité de gaz donc
je pense que la situation sociale sera
très très difficile malheureusement pour
les Français à la rentrée que vous
puissiez vous inspirer des propositions
de loi d'autres groupes voilà histoire
de petite habilités politiques pour les
piégés au moment du vote mais je pensais
par exemple de la situation du squat
pour la situation du squat tous les
propositions qu'on a fait pour lutter
contre le squat évidemment les
propositions qu'on a faites sous le
mandat précédent à Marine Le Pen avait
fait une proposition de loi sont en
train de rejoindre les nouvelles
propositions par exemple de la macronie
donc c'est un berger on peut trouver une
union
censé être su peut-être que mais ça vous
voudriez savoir si la majorité pourrait
voter votre proposition de loi oui par
exemple ce serait une façon de
heureusement j'ai un peu la réponse et
qui sont très sectaires je vous donne un
exemple Marine Le Pen avait déposé un
amendement pour aider les familles dans
l'accueil des enfants bon ils ont trouvé
que c'était un bon amendement au lieu de
reprendre une Marine Le Pen de le voter
ils en ont déposé un parallèlement bon
ils le font pour tous hein
en tout cas on a compris que
effectivement vous pourriez procéder
aussi de cette façon là merci beaucoup
Sophie dravignel dans un instant
Stéphane aurait dulier nous rejoint
sénateur vous avez accepté il a accepté
le débat avec vous ça va être
intéressant vous êtes un footeux comme
on dit ou pas supporter de foot elle a
pas du tout donc si je vous demande si
vous allez supporter l'équipe de France
dans le Mondial au Qatar vous me dites
quoi je supporte toujours enfin je le
soutiens toujours les équipes nationales
même si je ne suis pas familier du sport
donc je vous ferez sans problème le
boycott auquel appelle certains pour
dénoncer les conditions dans lesquelles
se déroule ce Mondial et dans lequel il
a été organisé avec éventuellement des
morts à la clé de personnes qui ont été
exploitées
de façon présumée dans sur les chantiers
qu'est-ce que vous répondez au RN était
le seul un des seules parties contre
l'attribution Qatar dès le début c'est
pas réveillé il y a 6 mois et par
exemple cet été il y a une convention
avec la gendarmerie l'État français a
envoyé un certain nombre de gendarmes
pour aider le Qatar là on a voté contre
en disant on peut pas envoyer ce signal
là de soutien un régime qui s'est très
mal comporté qui se comporte toujours
très mal la macronie et l'air ont voté
voilà donc moi si vous voulez fait faire
un boycott sur le dos des sportifs qui
sont pour rien dans l'attribution de de
cette coupe du monde ça me choque voilà
il fallait pas donner au Qatar
maintenant c'est fait et ben on fait
avec malheureusement je suis le je le
regrette elle est belle notre équipe de
France
sincèrement je mentirais en tirant je le
connais je ne la connais pas je ne
connais pas assez ses joueurs pour vous
pour être sincère et moi j'essaie d'être
sincère donc je n'ai pas d'avis sur
l'équipe de France vous êtes
quelques-uns en France
de football vous en êtes parce que dans
le passé facile de dire certains
fondateurs du Front national avait été
très critique à son égard vous ne la
connaissez pas
bonsoir Stéphane du lit merci beaucoup
de nous avoir rejoint et encore une fois
d'avoir accepté le principe du débat
vous avez choisi deux thèmes le premier
c'est la réforme des retraites oui
absolument j'ai lu avec attention à
l'interview de Madame Le Pen au JDD
j'étais assez surpris de cette forme de
rétropédalage qu'elle a pu faire dans le
cadre de l'âge pivot de départ en
retraite puisqu'elle revient sur cette
proposition phare de la campagne
présidentielle cette proposition que
vous avez soutenue de revenir sur l'âge
de départ en retraite de 62 à 60 ans
avec un argument quand même qui peut
s'entendre sur la dette publique plus de
600 milliards d'euros entre 2017 et 2022
de dette publique supplémentaire sauf
que ce chiffre là était connu défunt
2021 alors je serais tenté de dire
est-ce que potentiellement c'est un
retour à la réalité budgétaire et
financière de notre pays où est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à accompagner également
les républicains dans une réforme des
retraites qui
disons-le serait beaucoup plus large que
cet âge de départ en retraite et
parlerait des durées de cotisation la
pénibilité du travail l'alignement des
régimes spéciaux et de la fraude sociale
mais monsieur en fait ça du JDD ça c'est
la position du programme présidentiel de
2022 la notre position du féclage de
départ à la retraite doit dépendre de la
date d'entrée dans le monde du travail
et qui doit s'étendre de 60 à 62 ans
selon la date d'entrée vous soyez rentré
sur mon travail avant 20 ans ou après 20
ans c'est la nouvelle position de Marine
Le Pen à la présidentielle qui justement
avait pris en compte le bilan financier
catastrophique de Macron est dit on ne
peut plus tenir la promesse à 60 ans
parce que le finances publiques ne
permet plus et donc on a essayé de
trouver le meilleur système possible qui
intègre en fait ce que vous dites aussi
sur la pénibilité on a nous on essaie de
faire simple et je sais que là-dessus
les républicains sont souvent on est là
souvent d'accord sur le fait que la
technocratie trop compliquée que les
critères qui se multiplient en fait
rendent le système encore plus compliqué
qu'il n'était à l'origine on a considéré
que généralement sur l'essentiel des cas
les métiers les plus durs sont souvent
les métiers on commence à travailler tôt
et que donc en prenant le critère de
l'âge d'entrée dans le monde du travail
on intégrait en fait l'essentiel des
problèmes de pénibilité ce qu'empêche
pas de d'améliorer le système à la marge
après pour notamment les carrières
interrompues ou d'autres critères qui
seraient pas rentrer en jeu parlant avec
les nouvelles technologies ou les
nouveaux métiers notamment dans dans la
logistique qu'on puisse apparaître ou
des gens ont pu commencer plus tard mais
voilà la nouvelle position je sais
parfois je comprends pas pourquoi les
les républicains souvent sont toujours
attachés à l'illusion du fait que Marine
Le Pen promet toujours la retraite à 60
ans alors que c'est plus le cas depuis
de nombreuses années et que de la même
façon en fait nous pour nous ce qui
compte beaucoup et j'aimerais vous
entendre la saucisse et nous la question
de la nuitée parce qu'en fait ce qui
compte c'est pas tant là que le départ à
la retraite en lui-même qui est parce
que c'est souvent
oui non mais ça peut créer beaucoup
d'inégalités c'était ça la fin de ma
faute il est à 60 ans
qui ont commencé très tôt souvent des
métiers difficiles doivent en fait
cotiser un nombre d'annuité plus long
pour arriver à 62 63 64 ans alors que
les gens comme moi qu'on commençait leur
carrière professionnelle Tarbes qu'ils
ont fait des études peuvent arriver à 62
ans en ayant moins cotisé donc le
système de l'âge légal sous son air
simpliste contient en fait beaucoup
d'inégalités d'où l'importance des
annuités alors là je vous rejoins sur la
durée de cotisation effectivement je
pense que c'est un faux débat l'âge de
départ là je légale de départ en
retraite le seul souci c'est la notion
de barre et mise à Sion par rapport à la
pénibilité parce que quand on parle de
pénibilité parler de travail manuel
Macron ou autre mais il y a aussi
l'impact psychologique par rapport au
travail donc tout ça c'est d'essayer de
travailler sur une loi qui soit lisible
par tous et qui soit compréhensible par
tous mais dans le même temps qu'il soit
la plus juste possible or aujourd'hui on
a quand même des difficultés à définir
la notion de pénibilité et derrière
cette réforme des retraites il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont il faut
parler des régimes spéciaux on peut pas
demander des efforts en continu à une
certaine frange de la population sans
évoquer les 42 régimes spéciaux
les Français sont un peuples qui aiment
l'égalité la justice sociale donc ce
problème il est parfaitement posé mais
il y a aussi des régimes spéciaux qui
compensent des métiers très difficiles
je pense aux pécheurs je pense
évidemment à l'armée je pense aux
policiers bon tout ça aussi ce sont
issus des négociations tenant compte à
la fête de la pénibilité donc on
pourrait en fait à la fin si on applique
des barèmes de pénibilité on arriverait
finalement à la même situation est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord sur le principe
qu'il faut aussi étudier
ou aller jusqu'au bout qu'est-ce que
vous étiez en fait tous les cas des
régimes spéciaux quitte à les aligner si
on considère notamment qu'un régime
spécial n'a plus rien à voir donner un
exemple et on va le soumettre à Monsieur
Tanguy je prends souvent l'exemple du
conducteur de train avec cette fameuse
prime de charbon est-ce que aujourd'hui
on est encore dans cette logique de
pénibilité quand on conduit un TGV ou la
préfère bon c'est pas la question des
retraites mais oui ça c'est une prime
effectivement les gens sont choqués
parce que ça ne représente plus rien
mais de mémoire je crois que le régime
de la SNCF façon est en extinction mais
ceci dit ça posait problème parce que
moi dans les Hauts-de-France on manque
beaucoup de maintenant de conducteurs de
train donc en fait on découvre votre
question en fait conduire un train c'est
pas si facile que ça visiblement il y a
pas beaucoup de vocation la RATP aussi
les chauffeurs de bus on manque beaucoup
de chauffeurs de bus donc vous avez
raison je pense que le régime spécial en
fait il y a une incompréhension créer
des injustices mais ce qu'on n'a pas
voulu aussi parler des salaires vous
entendre que vous ne voulez pas les
supprimer et parce que ça n'est pas très
clair
évidemment tout de suite les gens sont
choqués mais une fois qu'on l'a supprimé
on se rend compte que les gens ne
veulent pas venir travailler dans ces
métiers parce qu'on n'a pas aligné
les conditions salariales et conditions
de travail donc si vous voulez supprimer
le régime spécial il faut remettre sur
la table d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se fait
souvent puisque on a besoin de recruter
des gens il faut mettre sur la table la
question des salaires moi dans les
Hauts-de-France je n'ai plus personne
pour conduire les trams monsieur
sur la fraude sociale pour des comptes
15 milliards
je pense que pour les républicains en
tout cas il est inconcevable de
proclamer une réforme des retraites et
demander des efforts supplémentaires à
tous les Français sans s'attaquer
durablement à cette à cette fraude
sociale et en même temps générer des
droits supplémentaires notamment pour
les petites retraites je pense aux
agriculteurs ceux qui ont travaillé
43-45 les veuves 50 ans les veuves pour
amener le niveau minimum de retraite
au-delà de 1200 ou 1300 euros est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
proposition d'accord Marine Le Pen est
proposé même un ministère de plein
exercice consacré à la lutte contre la
fraude nous on a retenu le chiffre
d'ailleurs qui vient souvent du Sénat
qui a fait un très bon travail sur les
fraudes donc nous c'est on a repris les
conclusions on n'est pas du tout dans le
sectarisme on partage particulièrement
cet objectif on a voté l'amendement des
républicains sur les cartes vitales bon
c'est une autre type de fraude mais nous
on est une fois plus on est tous
essentiels
qui sont versées indument dans certains
pays où il y a un centenaires qui sont
complètement hallucinant des gens donc
par exemple il faudrait que au moins et
je pense que l'action peut se rejoindre
4 de manière régulière les retraités
dans des pays extérieurs se présentent
au consulat pour vérifier que la
personne est bien vivante et que c'est
bien la personne qui reçoit la retraite
qui la mérite vraiment donc il y a
effectivement un enjeu sur la fraude et
là où on peut se rejoindre c'est que le
gouvernement pour des raisons
mystérieuses ne veut pas l'affronter
frontalement mais là où par contre
parfois les républicains en tout cas
l'assemblée puisque on n'a pas
au Sénat nous on va régulièrement je
crois qu'on va être 70% des amendements
LR ce qui prouve bien qu'on a pas de
sectarisme dans votre rencontre mais
vous vous ne votez jamais les
amendements du RN je vais pas répondre à
la place des députés je suis sénateur
vous avez un autre thème
les droits de succession passionnant
droit de succession l'impôt dit sur la
mort en tout cas c'est comme ça que les
républicains l'ont qualifié durant la
campagne de 2021 2022 on avait une
proposition très forte c'est la
suppression ces impôts de succession il
faut savoir que près de 14 pays de
l'OCDE l'ont supprimé que cette impôts
et de nature confiscatoire plus de 45%
parfois au niveau au niveau du du
prélèvement qui ne touche pas forcément
uniquement les familles moi je pense aux
travailleurs qui ont toute leur vie
construit un patrimoine qu'il léguer à
leur à leurs enfants qui a déjà été
moult fois taxé et malheureusement
ce patrimoine et de nouveaux taxés dans
le cas de la succession mais je pense
aussi et on en parle rarement du
patrimoine familial d'un point de vue
entrepreneurial beaucoup d'entreprises
familiales sont vouées à la disparition
parce que les héritiers ne peuvent pas
payer ces impôts de succession est-ce
que vous serez prêt à supprimer les
droits de succession comme le sujet avec
un palier quand même à partir vous êtes
comme érections à partir de 5 millions
évidemment on n'applique pas
l'exonération oui mais c'est un point
d'accord du programme de Marine Le Pen
et de Valérie Pécresse sur ce point mais
il y a pas besoin de se disputer surtout
vous avez raison sur ces valeurs là sur
ces valeurs là sur ces valeurs mais sur
ces valeurs là sur les valeurs de
travail de transmission on partage
exactement le même souci sur le fait de
la de pérenniser notamment les
exploitations forestières agricoles qui
grande difficulté parfois les
transmettent pour cet axe là n'est parf
là-dessus d'ailleurs au PLF et on a voté
les amendements LR qui allaient dans ce
sens là pour exclure en fait de droits
de succession toutes les classes
moyennes jusqu'au classement moyenne
supérieur et la quasi-totalité
effectivement des entreprises et des
biens professionnels ça on est
parfaitement d'accord mais une fois plus
de justice sociale la droite succession
comme le plaid parfois certains
économistes mais en fait je comprends
mais vous savez les impôts il y a deux
objectifs il y a l'objectif
rappelez-moi la proportion française qui
ne sont pas touchées par les droits de
succession parce que les
héritages sont trop faibles c'est les
deux tiers c'est plus des deux tiers
mais le tiers parce que c'est aussi le
tiers qui est taxé toujours le tiers qui
a l'impression d'être taxé pour tout
voilà ce sont notamment les classes
moyennes et les classes moyennes
supérieures qui ont l'impression comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur
qu'à la fin ils ont travaillé toute leur
vie ils ont été accès je rappelle que le
niveau des taxes en France c'est 45%
qu'ils ont été taxés toute leur vie et
qu'à la fin ils sont encore taxés une
dernière fois donc je pense que c'est un
signal politique important vous voyez
parce que dans la fiscalité vous avez
aussi
les valeurs de la société qui sont
transmises voilà et donc vous avez là un
terrain d'accord
je regrette c'est que LR quand on fait
le régulier ne le soutiennent pas là
vous parlez de l'Assemblée
véritablement une mesure de salut public
pour l'économie française si tu es un
chiffre quand même les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire quand on compare le
nombre d'entreprises de taille
intermédiaires de la France par rapport
à nos voisins
5500 entreprises de Thaïlande
intermédiaires l'Allemagne c'est 12000
absolument donc véritablement on voit
bien que c'est un point clé capitaliste
familial qui permettrait effectivement
une relance de l'économie vous parliez
tout à l'heure si j'ai bien entendu de
souveraineté industrielle ça passe aussi
par les petites et moyennes entreprises
le fait que le capital soit tenu par les
familles qui sont solidaires de leur
histoire personnelle de la transmission
qui fait que les savoir-faire ne soient
pas perdus dans la nature c'est très
important et effectivement l'Allemagne
l'Italie du Nord ont gardé ce
capitalisme familial qui leur a permis
de les protéger de la mondialisation et
de la prédation de la prédation de la
finance qui sait très bien qu'il y a des
pépites et qui sont très heureux de
prendre des pépites construites par des
générations de famille française et de
leur salarié Stéphane rue dulier vous
êtes un peu dire un proche de Bruno
Retailleau qui fait campagne pour la
présidence de LR le premier tour aura
lieu je crois à partir du 3 décembre il
y a trois candidats monsieur Retailleau
monsieur Thib monsieur Pradier pas de
femme
quel est votre candidat Jean-Philippe
Tanguy nous nous sommes souvenus à tout
niveau donc nous respectons la
souveraineté de républicains à choisir à
choisir leur leader voilà que bon
monsieur Pradier
est absolument odieux avec le RN et ses
élus depuis toujours voilà donc je pense
qu'il a sur moi de gauche
je suis pas dans sa tête qui est
vivement et mal faite mais monsieur
Pradier est il est absolument audio avec
nous voilà donc il faut le savoir
Monsieur cioti et plutôt aimable mais il
a une réaction étrange avec l'affaire
Fournas ah il a un peu reculé monsieur
Retailleau était le plus courageux dans
cette affaire il faut bien le il faut
bien le reconnaître
le plus sincère possible et bon monsieur
n'a pas voté le traité de Lisbonne ce
qui est aussi évidemment très rare
voilà Monsieur retailleux après une fois
plus je ne comprends pas par contre là
c'est pas le fait qu'il soit député il
est bien sénateur et il laissait passer
deux fois Monsieur Macron surtout la
deuxième fois et n'est pas pris parti en
tout cas pas forcément pris parti pour
Marine Le Pen en tout cas appelé à faire
barrage à faire barrage à Monsieur
Macron parce que vous là les
républicains vous pouvez pas dire qu'il
savait pas qui était monsieur Macron
notamment sur les questions migratoires
régalienne européenne voilà donc une
fois plus c'est quelque chose qui qu'on
a pas compris et d'ailleurs j'ai écouté
attentivement
vous pouvez entendre également qu'on on
veut préserver notre espace politique
clairement il faut faire un choix
c'est-à-dire que la droite républicaine
c'est pas n'est pas fongible dans le
rassemblement national ni dans la
macronie c'est véritablement en tout cas
la position de Bruno retaillod et dès
lors quand on travaille sur les textes
au Sénat on se pose quand il faut se
poser et par contre on peut voter pour
telle ou tel texte ou tel ou tel
disposition quand ça va dans l'intérêt
général du pays c'est ça aussi une
opposition responsable mais au-delà du
fait de votre mandat de sénateur et de
parlementaire français vous êtes aussi
un citoyen français et vous allez faire
un choix comme d'autres au second tour
de la présidentielle bah alors tout il
fallait le faire il fallait le faire
entre l'abstention le choix pour Marine
Le Pen ou au moins le choix contre
Monsieur Macron et le fait que les
républicains notamment quand vous êtes
quand on a quelqu'un qui est voté contre
le traité de Lisbonne c'est plus que
c'est une histoire commune en tout cas
des souverainiste français dans le suit
avec Monsieur rotaillot je ne comprends
pas qu'il est pas eu le courage de de
faire barrage à Monsieur Macron voilà
après c'est pas grave
ou qui vous éloigne du RN aujourd'hui
Monsieur Laurent
écoutez nous on trace notre route et ne
pas répondre à la question on trace
notre route j'ai pas on a autant
d'éléments qui nous rapprochent et qui
nous séparent du RN et de la macronie
moi j'ai qu'un seul et ennemi c'est
nupes la France insoumise d'accord à
l'Assemblée nationale voilà mais vous
êtes au Sénat on le rappelle sénateurs
merci beaucoup encore une fois
accepter cet échange l'ancien régime
comme disait Macron l'ancien monde je
peux croire que quand je vois les débats
à l'Assemblée nationale je suis vraiment
ravi d'être au Sénat d'être dans une
ambiance apaisée mais aussi constructive
non j'ai pas dit ça mais je trouve
déplorable l'attitude de certains
certains députés dans le cas notamment
des questions gouvernement mais ce n'est
pas l'essentiel du travail législatif
j'en conviens mais quand des séances de
QAG de questions gouvernement ne peuvent
plus se tenir qu'on est obligé de
suspendre deux semaines ensuite en
semaine ça donne véritablement une
déplorable de la démocratie
représentative
est à nouveau avec nous depuis
encore une question pour vous de la part
de
roue c'est à VOUS Vincent merci beaucoup
Elisabeth oui la question baisse une
question politique étrangère tout à
l'heure vous avez dénoncé
l'agression
l'invasion criminelle de l'Ukraine par
la Russie
Jean-Philippe Tanguy
est-ce que question est-ce que la la
reprise de Kerson par l'Ukraine doit
être la première étape à la reconquête
d'un territoire qui est occupé par la
Russie et annexée par la Russie
maintenant depuis 8 ans la Crimée
non ce sont deux sujets différents
l'Ukraine doit récupérer
oui d'accord mais là vous me demandez
mon avis donc le la reconquête la
reconquête des territoires envahis par
la Russie et les revient à l'Ukraine et
c'est une belle victoire pour l'Ukraine
pour le droit international nous pensons
des aventures pensées d'ailleurs il y
avait excusez-moi un large consensus en
fait dans la dans la vie politique
française puisqu'elle agression que la
Crimée est un territoire particulier le
référendum qui s'est tenu le bah oui à
droite notamment je suis désolé il y
avait un consensus à droite pour dire
que OUI OUI pour dire que la Crimée que
la Crimée que le référendum en Crimée
rétablissait une continuité historique
alors on peut être des accords sur les
conditions par ailleurs mais je pense
qu'il faut dissocier
dans la position pour rassemblement
national permettez-vous de le dire quand
même sauf que c'est assez vrai en fait
et ce que je voulais dire c'est que le
but ce n'est pas la guerre infinie le
but c'est de arriver à et je me réjouis
parce que pendant un moment il y a eu
beaucoup de déclarations bellicistes
maintenant il y avait un sommet à Paris
on revient à un consensus pour essayer
de relancer les discussions d'armistice
les discussions de paix ça doit être
notre priorité à tous chaque jour de
guerre c'est une jour de victimes sur
les négociations
très en coulisses C'est très en amour
une volonté et là où il y a une volonté
que je veux croire qu'il y a un chemin
tout à fait la Martichoux et en tout cas
si vous voulez être croire que je pense
que déjà si on résout de manière qu'on
arrive à trouver une solution pacifique
à la rétablissement de la souveraineté
ukrainienne
qu'on comprend le risque si on vous le
dossier de la Crimée on prend le risque
d'une guerre euh
même au prix d'une élection même au prix
d'une invasion donc la Crimée russe
mais la Crimée a été un excellent aussi
suite à référendum donc je pense que
rouvrir le dossier de la Crimée
il y a eu d'autres référendum un excès
des territoires
occupé par la rue ces dernières années
dans des pays en guerre qui sont une
mémoire même pas une semaine avec une
processus complètement ridicule que
personne n'a reconnu ce qui n'est pas le
cas du référendum en Crimée il y a pas
eu de réfugiés je vous rappelle qu'il y
a pas d'habitants Crimée qu'on demandait
de quitter le territoire il y a pas eu
de réfugiés politiques en Crimée ce qui
est un signe que les habitants de Crimée
avaient l'air de partager le d'avoir
partagé la décision qui était prise mais
je vous dis si on ouvre le dossier de la
Crimée se renouvelle le dossier de la
Crimée on enterre la possibilité d'une
armistice à court terme ce qui doit être
la priorité de tout le monde la réponse
est claire merci beaucoup Jean-Philippe
juste mais très vite oui ou non une PPL
sur la corrida c'était une question
Brigitte boucher serait examiné mercredi
en commission que vont faire les députés
à Rennes et la liberté de vote sur cette
question et vous moi je pense que je
voudrais compte parce que je n'aime pas
ce genre d'interdiction c'est une
civilisation voilà bon merci c'est fini
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi cette
émission merci encore d'avoir accepté
les débats et bien sûr bonne soirée sur
LCP Public Sénat on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à 19h30